so did he accept
the divorce at first like really well
and then it kind of shifted i think we
went off and on you know we went about
eight months without even speaking to
each other at the beginning of the
divorce for kim kardashian it seems
silence is golden at least when it comes
to her ongoing divorce from kanye west
and then you know we started talking
again and i went to the dondre premiere
i mean he would still see the kids and
stuff it just fit you know him and i
just
took a minute of not talking and i think
it all in relationships it'll it'll be
like that you just gotta roll with it
and during the latest episode of deer
media's not skinny but not fat podcast
the 41 year old reality star also opens
up about the rapper's social media rants
against her remember this one most men
do not there's no such thing as 50 50
custody
with with in society today that's not
that's not even
it always leans towards the mom but for
kim she says she approached all that
with compassion it doesn't mean that
maybe because he expressed himself in a
certain way that he's not an amazing
person an amazing friend i do believe
that we'll have that again i'm always
really hopeful and
you know he's an amazing dad and and
i never really also judge the way
someone wants to communicate whether
it's the way i would or not i try to
just
like i know who he is inside and now it
seems kanye is trying to get to a better
place with kim for the sake of their
kids last month et learned the grammy
winner told the beauty mogul he's going
to get help and has agreed to stop
harassing her and cyberbullying her
current boyfriend pete davidson you'll
recall kanye rapt about the snl star in
his latest single easy god send me from
that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
our source says for the sake of kim and
kanye's four little ones north saint
chicago and salm yeh told kim he's not
making any public appearances or
inflammatory social media statements and
he will go away somewhere to get better
just do something for my heart a rep
friend tells e.t quote at this time yay
is committed to a healthy co-parenting
relationship with kim and is focused on
raising their beautiful children and the
skim's founder is positive they will
reach that place you know i look back
and my mom and dad went through their
hard time and it took people a minute to
readjust and
i've seen it all before i think we just
have a different kind of platform
now i hope we are the co-parenting goals
at the end of the day it's a sentiment
kim's sister chloe echoed to e.t back in
2019. i think everyone has to handle
their co-parenting situation in their
own style but my mom and my dad were
like that it took them years but my dad
would come over once a week for family
dinners and would play golf with my
stepdad and so we come from a family
where we believe in that and you share
children with people and that's how it
should be it's a beautiful thing to get
along with each other and for your kids
to see that for now it seems kim is
focused on the future including her
blossoming romance with pete i like you
just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
and that moment that sparked it all is
something we'll see more of on the
family's new reality series on hulu what
do you love about him what's your
favorite thing about it
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing that's the goal
is finding someone to do nothing with
it's the best
[Music]
you